نا للاخبار العاجله التي ظهرت قبل قليل
على شاشتنا بحسب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
الهجمات ضد السفن يقول في البحر الاحمر
يجب ان تتوقف وسنفعل كل ما يلزم للحد منها
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني يقول ايضا ضربتنا
العسكريه للحوثيين محدوده ومتناسب وجاءت
ردا على تهديد مباشر ل سفننا ويضيف هجمات
الحوثيين على الشحن الدولي عرضت ارواح
ابرياء للخطر وسببت ضررا اقتصاديا كبيرا
ويردف قواتنا متيق وجاهزه لردع الحوثيين
مجددا هذا ما جاء اذا على لسان رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني قبل قليل المزيد معنا
الان من لندن مراسل الجزيره محمد المدهون
واهم جا اذا في هذه التصريحات وما هي اهم
الرسائل نعم سفيان هذه المره الاولى التي
يتاح فيها لرئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريش
سوناك اطلاع نواب مجلس العموم على الغارات
الجويه التي نفذتها طائرات مقاتله
بريطانيه مع الامريكيين يوم الخميس الماضي
في ساعه متاخره من ليله الخميس ولم يكن
البرلمان قد انعقد خلال الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه كان في اجازه ورغم عرض رئيس مجلس
العموم على رئيس الوزراء بان يدعو
البرلمان لنقاش هذه الغارات الا انه رفض
ذلك العرض وهو اليوم امام نواب مجلس
العموم يستقبل اسئلتهم بشان هذه الغارات
والاحتجاجات من بعضهم لذهابه لعمل عسكري
دون استشاره نواب مجلس العموم ودون
التصويت ودون حتى نقاش هذه المساله الموقف
البريطاني مازال ثابتا لم يتغير يقول ريش
السنك ان بلاده لن تتردد في استهداف مواقع
الحوثيين مجددا اذا ما استمرت هذه الهجمات
على السفن التجاريه والسفن الحربيه ايضا
يقول ان هجمات الحوثيين استهدفت سفينه
حربيه بريطانيه في اكبر هجوم من نوعه منذ
عقود يستهدف سفينه حربيه بريطانيه وهو
يؤكد ان هذا الفعل كان ضروريا ومتناسب
ومحدودا وموجها وجاء دفاعا عن النفس وبعد
ان استنفدت كل الخيارات الدبلوماسيه اجرت
المملكه المتحده يقول سنك خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه التي شنت فيها جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين هذه الهجمات على السفن التجاريه
والحربيه اجرت الكثير من الاتصالات
والجهود الدبلوماسيه لوقف هذه الهجمات لكن
الحوثيين لم يتوقفوا
والرساله واضحه من البريطانيين بان
الاقوال ستتبعها افعال وسيكون هناك المزيد
من الهجمات لكن موجه الغارات الجويه التي
نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه البريطانيه يفترض
لها ان تكون محدوده وال تتكرر الا اذا
عادت الهجمات من جماعه انصار الله الحوثي
مجددا الخيار قائم ولكن يراد لها ان تكون
موجه واحده وقد اكد وزير الدفاع البريطاني
جران شابس في وقت سابق اليوم بان بريطانيا
لا ترغب بتجديد هذه الغارات لكنها لن
تتردد في فعل ذلك اذا تطلب الامر شكرا
محمد المدهون كنت معنا من لندن اشكرك
مستمرون مشاهدي